Затуманене місто з 15 поверху. Для Максима Залевського бачити столицю з висоти
- звична справа. Адже у київському небі він піднімав і приземляв сотні літаків.
Аж доки у повітряний простір України не зайшли ворожі ракети та авіація.
Я знав, що аеропорти почали закриватися ще вночі.
На деяких з них блокували злітно-посадкові смуги.
Тобто було розуміння, що щось відбувається і що вони це просто так не робили б.
Після того, як я почитав новини, перше, що я зробив - зателефонував батькам.
По-перше, дізнатися, як у них справи. По-друге, батьку в цей день виповнилося 60.
От таке-от вітаннячко.
А далі - понад два місяці без польотів і найбільша пауза за чотири роки роботи.
Свою форму пілота Максим одягнув лише наприкінці квітня, щоби сісти за штурвал
евакуаційних та гуманітарних бортів, а вже згодом додалися й пасажирські рейси.
Авіакомпанія SkyUp, де працює Максим, почала здійснювати
чартерні перевезення для туроператорів та укладати лізингові контракти
з європейськими колегами. Простими словами: компанія почала здавати в оренду
літак разом із екіпажем і технічним обслуговуванням.
Десь утричі впав об’єм роботи. Але якщо ми тримаємо в голові те,
що в три рази впав об’єм роботи, коли в тебе в країні війна, – я вважаю,
що це чудовий результат. Я не розраховував працювати за спеціальностю
в принципі після таких новин. Улітку в нас була задіяна максимальна кількість літаків
і максимальна кількість пілотів. Я навіть з гордістю можу сказати,
що це було дуже гарне літо щодо обсягів роботи.
Продовжити комерційні польоти й зберегти штат - а це понад 1200 співробітників -
вдалося завдяки тому, що до 24 лютого компанія евакуювала з України
майже весь флот, пояснюють у SkyUp. Сьогодні ж керівники працюють над тим,
щоб створити окрему компанію для роботи на європейському ринку.
Це навіть не стільки мета, скільки необхідність:  для того, щоб українська авіакомпанія
могла оперувати в європейському просторі, здійснювати рейси в країнах ЄС,
необхідно отримати відповідний сертифікат експлуатанта ЄС.
Що дасть нам можливість оперувати і здійснювати не лише чартерні,
а й регулярні рейси в наступному році вже з європейським сертифікатом,
що, безумовно, нам допоможе продовжити операційну діяльність, зберегти наш штат.
З перших місяців повномасштабного вторгнення евакуаційні та чартерні рейси
також здійснювала ще одна українська авіакомпанія - МАУ.
Втім, польоти призупинили у жовтні через внутрішні непорозуміння:
між акціонерами та керівництвом. Усі ж інші - чотирнадцять українських авіакомпаній,
які працювали до 24 лютого - після закриття повітряного простору
заморозили свою операційну діяльність. А це означає, що тисячі фахівців галузі
нині залишаються без роботи. До того ж, такі тривалі професійні паузи в авіації
мають свої наслідки, особливо для членів екіпажу.
Уже пройшло більше ніж пів року. Сертифікати цих пілотів уже будуть під величезним питанням.
Таким пілотам доведеться або самостійно вкладати кошти для того, щоб повторно
проходити навчання. Або тій авіакомпанії, в якій вони працюють або будуть працювати,
доведеться знову інвестувати кошти і час для того, щоб цей пілот знову повернувся в стрій.
Більшість компаній намагаються якимось чином зберігати кваліфікацію
або хоча б забезпечувати одиничні рейси в інших партнерських компаніях
для того, щоб хоча б зберігати допуск і сертифікати.
Про співпрацю з європейськими колегами заради збереження сертифікатів
екіпажу домовилася низка українських авіакомпаній.
Зокрема й МАУ, в якій до 24 лютого бортпровідницею працювала Юлія Чипак.
Місяць навчання, вдалий іспит - і вже наприкінці квітня Юлія одягла форму
чеської авіакомпанії. А згодом переїхала до Ізраїлю.
Я довго пручалась, дуже довго пручалась: "Ні, я не полечу. Буде в нас все добре".
Але все-таки здоровий глузд спрацював. Кожна компанія пропонувала свій період.
Наприклад, чому я обрала Smartwings - бо контракт був на пів року.
Нас найбільша частина, до речі, українок-бортпровідниць саме в Smartwings.
Ми просто наївно вірили, що за пів року ми повернемося додому.
У жовтні чеська авіакомпанія запропонувала Юлії та іншим українським бортпровідницям
постійну роботу в штаті.
Нас зараз в Ізраїлі 35 українських колег. І це не лише компанія МАУ.
Це і SkyUp, і Azur Air, і "Роза вітрів". І нам перші пів року було надзвичайно важко.
Дуже було важко адаптуватися. І навіть оце притирання з чеськими колегами,
зі словаками, в нас французи, в нас максимальний мікс… Але ми працюємо просто…
Без перебільшення. Ми працюємо ідеально. Я думаю, саме через це, як ми тепер чуємо
від менеджменту авіакомпаній, нас залишили. Вони кажуть: "Ви - просто неймовірні!"
І справді: українські авіаційні працівники за кордоном - на вагу золота.
Через те, що вони готові працювати краще на тих же умовах, наприклад,
на яких можуть відмовлятися працювати інші працівники в європейських країнах.
Крім того, якщо ми говоримо про пілотів, то у деяких країнах навіть є дефіцит.
Наприклад, Китай постійно пілотів шукає.
Чим довше українське небо залишатиметься закритим - тим складніше буде
відновлювати авіаційну галузь, пояснює Богдан Долінце.
Борг компаній щоденно збільшується, працівники без роботи втрачають кваліфікацію,
а частина з тих, хто виїхав за кордон, назад до країни не повернеться.
Тож, після війни українській цивільній авіації доведеться "народжуватися" вдруге.
І, за словами експертів, вона більше не буде такою, як була до 24 лютого.
Гравці, географія й частота польотів неодмінно зміняться.
Авіакомпанії вже сьогодні починають аналізувати, що взагалі відбувається.
Якщо говорити про топ-3 країни - Польщу, Німеччину, Чехію - загалом в яких
майже 2 мільйони українців знаходиться на сьогодні. І навіть якщо половина
з них повернеться, там залишиться до мільйона потенційних пасажирів,
які матимуть в Україні родичів і буде потреба літати.
На відновлення польотів чекають тисячі працівників авіаційної галузі.
І поки війна змінює їхнє життя, віра в професію й країну залишається незмінною.
Я свято вірю, що саме в цей день я поїду в Бориспіль і з превеликою радістю
скажу привіт всім тим, хто там є. Ми готові до роботи!